foreign
we need to know that the things we're
producing are safe
are actually giving us the effect that
we are intending to create
as well as not causing any harm I think
there's a lot of Hope and promise
energize tools that are used
Source mindset allows you to ask all
kinds of possibilities you can go right
back and if you're not sure if
something's right you can go and explore
it I think there's a lot of value in
open source because that pipeline
although somewhat idiosyncratic and
unique across different Pharma companies
at the end of the day is standardized
you can get people who have both
industry experience they understand what
it is to build an atom data set they
understand that process and so they have
the right skills they're just a lot more
transferable so I use posit packages
almost every day when I'm working and it
makes it just incredibly easy to build a
package that is quality that it's tested
as a statistician for instance being
able to have an open source package
that's already available greatly
increases how quickly you can like try
that method out our submission process
is still based around essentially paper
submissions we've made the paper into
PDFs but it's pretty much the same as it
was 20 or 30 years ago by submitting to
Regulators with open source software
they can immediately access that same
code they can run it on their own
machines and verify that they are
getting the same results that we are
give them a lot of code
in order to show up this is all of the
things we did and when it's in our
package it's lovely it's easy that's
portable it's open source we don't even
have to Port it anywhere it's already
out there I think the possibility now
with with open source and particularly
something like R well you've got a tool
like shiny is you can start to deliver
that submission in a different way I
think will be we'll be sharing the data
directly with the Regulators in future
we'll be worried less about how we
format that and get it to look really
nice on a piece of paper and I hope that
we'll be able to deliver these kind of
interactive apps to Regulators in the
future
[Music]